so I need to warn you fair warning I am
new to this practice of talking about
social policy that's because until
recently I was engaged in implementing
social policy as the Commissioner of New
York City's largest public social
services agency I was responsible for
the day-to-day operation of some of our
nation's biggest anti-poverty programs
at the New York City human resources
administration we administered
everything from cash welfare to food
stamp benefits to Medicaid eligibility
to child support collections and a host
of other programs in between so my
perspective comes from someone who's
seen these programs work day to day over
a long period of time and what I learned
and what I saw was that government can
create an environment whereby people in
poverty can move in to work and raise
their incomes but it takes adherence to
certain core principles and those
principles are we must require work in
return for assistance we must also
reward work by making low wages go
farther we must always talk about
two-parent families and the importance
of mothers and fathers in the
appropriate raising of children and
finally we must be vigilant about
promoting a job producing growing
economy low wage jobs middle wage jobs
highway jobs providing opportunity to
low income Americans now I suppose it's
possible that you might be thinking how
did I how did someone like me get into
the poverty fighting world to begin with
I mean
look at me frankly I look kind of
Republican even even conservative and I
am but I chose to make my career helping
struggling Americans because of what I
saw in my father's career working in the
Civil Rights Division of the United
States Justice Department he came to
Washington in 1960 at the end of the
eyes our administration and joined the
Civil Rights Division at that point and
stayed through President Kennedy's
administration and almost to the end of
the Johnson administration and during
that time he was engaged or involved in
all of the really difficult problems and
conflicts that occurred during that time
and it was positive and forward-looking
and it made our country better and
ultimately it was inspiring because it
showed that government and us Americans
could improve our country and then at
the request of his friend Robert Kennedy
we moved to New York City where Robert
Kennedy had started a small anti-poverty
program in bedford-stuyvesant one of the
largest slums in America at the time a
neighborhood of 500,000 New Yorkers in
the central Brooklyn and my father was
involved in a small program bringing
economic development and and private
sector investment and some real estate
development and over his experience
there they made some small gains for a
few people on a few blocks in Brooklyn
but meanwhile larger forces were at work
larger forces were at work and they were
the welfare entitlement state that had
said as part of the reforms that took
place in the 60s and 70s we will provide
assistance to people without regard to
what they do as a matter of right or a
matter of entitlement so while a few
people were benefited by the
bedford-stuyvesant Restoration
Corporation hundreds of thousands were
sucked in to a life of dependence
and no work and our city was almost
brought to its knees so when I had a
chance to go to work in the government I
had those two things in my mind success
and civil rights not really success in
poverty and so I joined the Pataki
administration in 1995 luckily right at
the beginning of the welfare reform
movement in America Governor Zangler
governor's Thompson Bill Clinton Newt
Gingrich decided to change welfare as we
know it and I worked there for Governor
Pataki and then for mayor Giuliani for
that entire period and what did we do we
required work in return for public
assistance we made it a clear
expectation that it was a reciprocal
relationship between the receiver of
assistance and the provider of aid in
that regard we changed the names of our
offices they used to be called think of
this the welfare offices in New York
City usually called income maintenance
centers income maintenance centers we
changed them to be job centers we paid
people that tried to help people get
jobs only if they got jobs we paid for
performance we talked about child
support enforcement we said children
need two parents contributing there's a
responsibility for both parents to care
for their children and we created an
environment where if there wasn't a job
or someone couldn't work we said to them
what we need you to be involved in the
schedule and rigor on a day-to-day basis
of something that looks like a job we'll
provide assistance but we need you to be
in a circumstance where you're mirroring
the schedule and rigor of employment so
that's the tough stuff we also rewarded
work so public health insurance for
low-wage workers we were generous with
it
food stamp benefits for working people
we provided it childcare assistance the
Earned Income Tax Credit we promoted
these supports for low-wage workers so
wages could go further we talked about
family we promoted two-parent families
and always always we understood that in
order to succeed at its best
we needed a thriving job producing
economy and we didn't make any
disparagement about dead-end jobs or
low-wage jobs we said we need jobs any
job is a step up
so we promoted hospitality and
restaurants of health care and every
time I saw those economic development
guys in the halls of government I said
make it happen
we need jobs require work reward work
talk about family promote a strong
economy those are the four principles of
success in this endeavor so what
happened where were the statistics so
everyone knows welfare caseloads
plummeted the peak welfare caseload in
New York City was 1.1 million cash
welfare recipients one in seven New
Yorkers was receiving the dole recently
last year before I left we were down a
350,000 out of a city of more than 8
million tremendous decline but that
wasn't our greatest achievement our
greatest achievement was were crates for
never married mothers were crates for
never married mothers the very people
who were on cash welfare in the first
place the very first people who the
program's was originally set up to help
it went from 43 percent to 63 percent 20
percent point increase unprecedented and
remarkable and it happened all across
the country not only in New York City
child poverty in New York City declined
dramatically in the late 90s
up to - up into mm from 43% to 28%
significant decline in child poverty and
what was the most compelling statistic
of all and this is a national statistic
African American child poverty in the
United States dropped from 44% in 1994
to 30% in 2001 now think of that almost
half African American children were in
poverty before welfare reform less than
a third after welfare now since the
early 2000s I have to say I'm not sure
we've kept focused on those report those
core principles we've gotten away from
the require work requirements we've made
rewarding work sometimes replace work so
that some of the benefits we provide
provide disincentives to people being in
work we haven't talked about the
importance of two-parent families enough
and most egregiously we've allowed our
economy to not grow the greatest tragedy
of the anemic recovery we have been
through these last five years is the
damage it's done to poor Americans so
from someone who's been in the business
who's seen it work successfully and seen
it maybe not work so successfully
require work reward work talk about
family promote a strong economy those
are the keys now I have one last point I
want to make and this is an important
one it is a common desire to promise an
outcome to guarantee that we will if we
do this we will guarantee people's
rising safely into the middle class
governments can't promise that
they can't guarantee that people make
that happen
people make that happen if the
environment is created for that to
happen so to promise an outcome of that
kind to guarantee it as if it would as
if government could provide it it's a
false promise and it's a harmful promise
but if we create an environment whereby
people in poverty can move into work and
increase their incomes you know what
they'll do it they did it before they
proved all of the commentators and all
of the prognosticators wrong about what
would happen if we went to a work-based
welfare program they were the heroes of
welfare reform and we need to get back
to that kind of policy to help poor
Americans in the future thank you very
much thanks for watching
we'd like to know what you think about
fighting poverty so tell us in the
comments below
then please to help us spread the word
by sharing this video for more vision
talks click the subscribe button and
visit the website the pursuit of
happiness calm